- [Kelly] I have to ask about, obviously,
Randy Watson and Sexual
(laughs) Chocolate.
(audience laughs)
Was he inspired by anyone,
or did that just come up
out of your imagination?
- Not inspired by anybody.
Just came up, the way those,
all of those characters
come together by Rick Baker,
who designed those makeups.
He's retired now, a genius makeup artist.
And he would put the
makeups on me in a chair,
and then he would start
kinda talkin' to me like,
when it was about 80% done,
and askin' me questions, like,
"Hey, where you from?
Where you doin," and I'd
try different voices out
till the right voice that looks right
comin' outta that makeup.
And then we kinda, you kinda
make him up in the chair.
He comes to life in the chair.
- It's such a, you're so gifted at it,
like playing all those different roles
in all the different movies
I love seeing you in.
It's amazing, and it's gotta be fun,
because at least you're not
hired to do like one thing.
It's not monotonous, your character,
'cause you're playing so many things.
It's gotta be so exciting.
- It's rewarding, but it's not fun at all,
because the process-
- Oh (laughs).
(audience laughs)
- They haven't figured out
how to make the process any shorter.
You got, it's six hours of
putting those makeups on.
- That was-
- Not a fun thing.
- That was (laughs)
actually my favorite answer,
that anyone's ever said.
"It was rewarding, but like,
absolutely zero fun (laughs)."
- (laughs) It's true.
- "I actually hated my life,
but it's great, I'm glad you liked it."